Estoy seguro de que muchos estaréis de acuerdo
en que estos últimos años han sido toda
una locura: una pandemia, la guerra más grande
en Europa desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
una crisis energética o la inflación más
alta en varias décadas.
Vamos, que igual no llega a ser la época
más interesante de todos los tiempos como
dice Elon Musk, pero desde luego no está
dejando indiferente a casi nadie.
Y, por si fuera poco, parece que la vieja
dinámica de bloques ha revivido.
Algunos incluso dicen que la Guerra Fría
está regresando, solo que, esta vez, el principal
contrincante de Estados Unidos no es otra
unión de repúblicas socialistas como la
URSS, sino la República Popular China.
Y, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, si hay
algo que se toman muy, pero que muy en serio
en Washington, eso no es otra cosa que la
Seguridad Nacional.
De esta forma, en la Estrategia de Seguridad
Nacional que la Administración Biden publicó
en 2022, no dudaron en señalar directamente
a lo que consideran sus dos grandes amenazas,
China y Rusia.
("Estos competidores creen erróneamente que
la democracia es más débil que la autocracia
porque no comprenden que el poder de una nación
surge de su pueblo.
Estados Unidos es fuerte en el exterior porque
somos fuertes en casa.
Nuestra economía es dinámica.
Nuestra gente es resiliente y creativa.
Nuestro ejército sigue siendo incomparable,
y así seguirá siéndolo".
Presidente Joe Biden en la Estrategia de Seguridad
Nacional de 2022)Pero, queridos amigos, esto
es el siglo XXI.
Pese a lo que estamos viendo en Ucrania, hoy
en día las amenazas ya no vienen solamente
en forma de guerras convencionales.
La ciberseguridad y el uso de la inteligencia
artificial se están convirtiendo también
en dos grandes prioridades para las agencias
de seguridad nacional.
Y, eso ni siquiera es todo, en lo que llevamos
de siglo el uso de la guerra comercial y económica
también está adquiriendo cada vez más y
más importancia.
Por eso, y para completar una serie de vídeos
que hemos hecho sobre la situación de seguridad
en Estados Unidos - os dejo varios enlaces
en la descripción - en VisualPolitik nos
hemos hecho unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cuáles son realmente las grandes amenazas
a las que se enfrenta hoy por hoy Estados
Unidos?
¿Cómo de peligrosa es la rivalidad norteamericana
con China y Rusia?
¿Cómo estos países están intentando debilitar
económica y militarmente a la gran potencia
norteamericana?
¿Son las amenazas externas las únicas a
las que se enfrenta el Tío Sam?
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, en este
vídeo os vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas.
Arranquemos.
T1 (LAS NUEVAS FOR MAS DE LA GUERRA)
Todos tenemos más que claro que el ejército
de Estados Unidos es con mucha diferencia
el más poderoso de todo el mundo.
Pero, imaginad por un momento que Estados
Unidos y China comenzaran de repente una guerra
total, por tierra, mar y aíre.
Bombardeos aéreos, batallas navales, misiles,
ciberataques…
¿Creéis que en un escenario así China tendría
más éxito que el cosechado por Rusia en
Ucrania?
Pues, lo más probable es que sí.
A diferencia del país de Putin, China es
una superpotencia industrial y también, en
cierto modo, tecnológica.
También es un país mucho más grande y con
muchos más recursos y quizás por eso China
se está modernizando mucho más rápido que
Rusia.
(Siendo ya la segunda gran potencia económica
del mundo, tan solo por detrás de Estados
Unidos, China tiene capacidad de sobre para
mejorar su armamento y sus capacidades militares.
Una buena prueba de ello es la presentación
del portaaviones CNS Fujian, el tercer y más
avanzado portaaviones que ha producido y que
en ciertos campos compite directamente con
el más avanzado de los Estados Unidos, el
USS Gerald Ford, por ejemplo, en el uso de
catapultas electromagnéticas.
(Como os podéis imaginar, los nuevos portaaviones
que está construyendo China reforzaran su
dominio marítimo en toda la región . Sin
embargo, esto es solo la punta del iceberg,
ya que este país también está realizando
fuertes inversiones en la producción de misiles
hipersónicos, 6 veces más rápidos que los
cazas F-35 americanos.
No obstante, es su inversión en el ciberespacio
lo que más está llamando la atención.
De hecho, según Verizon, el 95% de todo el
ciberespionaje que sufre Estados Unidos proviene
precisamente de China.)
Por eso no es raro que de vez en cuando nos
encontremos con noticias como esta:
(25 de mayo 2023: Según la inteligencia occidental
hackers chinos espían infraestructuras críticas
de EE.UU.
Reuters)
(24 de mayo 2023: Los piratas informáticos
chinos que atacan EE.UU. y Guam pretenden
interrumpir las comunicaciones, según Microsoft.
Guam se ha convertido en un centro estratégico
cada vez más importante para EE.UU.Bloomberg)
(2 octubre, 2022: Según un análisis, un
grupo chino de piratas informáticos ataca
a agencias y empresas de EE.UU. y ha incrementado
su actividad, según un análisis.
CNN)
En realidad, la mayor amenaza a la que ahora
mismo se está enfrentando Estados Unidos
por parte de otros estados son los ciberataques.
Pero ¡ojo!
No solo de China, Rusia, por ejemplo, tampoco
se queda corta.
De hecho, en febrero de 2022, Estados Unidos
expulsó a 12 oficiales de la misión rusa
en la ONU por haber estado llevando a cabo
operaciones de espionaje y ciberespionaje.
Sin embargo, la preocupación de Estados Unidos
también se extiende a una opción que Putin
ha puesto sobre la mesa durante su invasión
a Ucrania: el uso de armas nucleares.
Ya todo sabemos que Rusia es la mayor potencia
nuclear del mundo y que China está muy cerca
de superar a la India, Pakistán y Corea del
Norte.
Sin embargo, Estados Unidos tiene los ojos
puestos en otro actor, fijaos en esta noticia:
(Irán nuclear: los inspectores del OIEA hallan
partículas de uranio enriquecido al 83,7.
BBC)
Exacto, no creo que sea ninguna sorpresa para
nadie, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, al
tío Sam le preocupa Irán.
El país de los Ayatolás está consiguiendo
enriquecer el uranio hasta niveles que muy
próximos a lo que se necesita para desarrollar
armas nucleares.
Y eso es algo que podría crear un inmenso
caos en Oriente Medio.
Israel, Arabia Saudí, Turquía…
Prácticamente, todo el mundo se volvería
loco en esta región si finalmente los Ayatollahs
se hacen con la bomba.
El riesgo sería demasiado alto.
El régimen iraní sería intocable, incluso,
por ejemplo, en lo que respecta al estrecho
de Ormuz, que es por donde pasa gran parte
del petróleo que consumen países como Corea
del Sur, Japón o la propia Taiwán.
¿Y de quién es aliado Irán?
3,2,1…
¡Exacto!
De la China de Xi Jinping, ¿empezáis ya
a atar cabos?
Así que tenemos a China, a Rusia, a Irán,
la guerra convencional, la guerra híbrida
y los ciberataques.
Todos ellos son riesgos relativamente nuevos
que se han creado o han vuelto a crecer en
las últimas dos décadas.
Y la pregunta es, ante todo esto, ¿qué está
haciendo Estados Unidos?
Pues, como no podía ser de otra forma, no
se van a quedar con los brazos cruzados.
Y eso es lo que explica noticias como esta:
N5 (Biden prepara el mayor presupuesto de
la historia para el Pentágono mientras se
avecinan recortes de gastos.
Politico)
No lo dudéis, el Tío Sam va a pisar el acelerador.
Va a seguir gastando cantidades masivas de
dinero para intentar seguir siendo muy superior
a todos sus adversarios en todos los frentes.
(Con todos los ciberataques que sufre, la
administración Biden ha hecho de la ciberseguridad
un pilar central.
Por eso, el Ejército de Estados Unidos ya
ha desplegado varios equipos encargados de
la ciberseguridad y también equipos para
llevar a cabo sus propios ciberataques.
Asimismo, con el desarrollo tecnológico,
especialmente de China, el Pentágono está
reforzando su apuesta y destinando miles y
miles de millones de dólares a la robótica,
la inteligencia artificial, la tecnología
láser y el desarrollo de sistemas de ataque
y defensa hipersónicos.
Por ejemplo, en los últimos años Lockheed
Martin ha instalado el sistema HELIOS en todos
los destructores de la Marina americana.
Es decir, que Estados Unidos ya cuenta en
su flota con armas láser capaces de derribar
aviones y hundir barcos.
En otras palabras, estamos presenciando los
prolegómenos de una nueva carrera militar.)
Claro, que esta que hemos visto es la parte
de las amenazas más convencional.
Pero estamos en pleno siglo XXI y si algo
hemos aprendido es que estas no son las únicas
amenazas que existen a nivel internacional.
Podemos encontrar muchas más posibilidades.
Y una de las que más están sonando últimamente
es precisamente esta…
T2 (EL IMPERIO DEL DÓLAR…
¿EN APUROS?)
Todos recordamos a Joe Biden decir que convertiría
a Rusia en un paria internacional después
de que invadiera Ucrania.
Y lo decía en serio: las sanciones que impuso
junto a la Unión Europea han hecho que muchos
países del mundo ya no estén tan seguros
a la hora de relacionarse con Rusia por miedo
a sufrir sanciones.
Pero, por supuesto, Rusia ya ha encontrado
un socio que en cierta forma le cubra las
espaldas: China.
Atrás quedaron las viejas disputas de la
Guerra Fría.
Hoy China y Rusia mantienen una sólida relación
que se extiende desde el campo militar hasta
la energía, las finanzas y el comercio.
Sin embargo, a excepción de la energía,
la relación es más bien desigual.
Por ejemplo, mientras los productos chinos
suponen un 18% de todo lo que importa Rusia,
los productos rusos apenas representan el
2% de lo que China importa del resto del mundo.
Pero, desde luego, no es la única asimetría
entre ambos, fijaos:
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
desde que se pusieran en marcha de las sanciones
que impiden a Rusia comerciar fácilmente
con dólares o euros, Rusia ha hecho del yuan
su moneda principal para las transacciones
internacionales.
Y no solo eso, también se ha convertido en
su principal moneda de reserva.
Pero esto no debería sorprender a nadie,
al fin y al cabo, ambos países forman parte
de la Organización de Cooperación de Shanghái
y han estado impulsando el comercio con monedas
locales en lugar de con dólares.
Y, no solo eso, en 2015 Rusia y China también
suscribieron una alianza financiera que reforzaba
esta misma idea.
De hecho, aunque algunos grandes bancos chinos
han dejado de relacionarse con Rusia por miedo
a violar las sanciones internacionales, los
pequeños y medianos no están haciendo lo
mismo.
Por eso, Rusia ha podido esquivar en cierta
forma algunas de las principales sanciones,
por ejemplo, usando infraestructuras de pago
alternativas para superar el bloqueo Swift
de muchos de sus bancos.
Con todo, no es extraño que Putin diga cosas
como esta:
C2 (“Estamos a favor de usar el yuan chino
para los pagos entre Rusia y los países de
Asia, África y América Latina” Putin después
de su última reunión con Xi Jinping este
año 2023)
Ahora bien, dependen del Yuan, también tiene
muchos problemas.
Os hemos hablado de ello en un reciente vídeo
que tenéis en la descripción.
Cambiar el control de Washington por el de
Pekín tampoco parece la mejor idea del mundo.
Y por eso desde Rusia se ha barajado otra
posibilidad: crear una moneda entre los BRICS.
Para los que no lo recordéis, el término
BRICS se refiere a las siglas de 5 grandes
economías emergentes: Brasil, Rusia, India,
China y Sudáfrica.
Entre ellos suponen casi la mitad de la población
mundial y una quinta parte del PIB global.
Con semejantes números, no parece descabellado
pensar que pudieran crear una moneda capaz
de competir con el dólar.
Ya no es solo que ellos la utilizarán, es
que podrían hacer que muchos otros países
también la adaptaran para el comercio internacional…
Y así poco a poco podría crearse una enorme
red de operaciones en la moneda de los BRICS.
Por ejemplo, si Tailandia tiene que empezar
a usar esta moneda para comerciar con China,
desde Brasil podrían seguir comprando productos
tailandeses sin tener que usar otra moneda
diferente, porque a Tailandia también le
vendría bien cobrar en esa divisa.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Y todo esto para qué?
Pues básicamente para acabar con el dominio
del dólar, reducir los capitales internacionales
que terminan en Estados Unidos y de paso impedir
que Washington pueda aprovechar su posición
para aplicar sanciones a diestro y siniestro.
Claro que tampoco resulta nada fácil.
El dólar es demasiado fuerte y, seamos honestos,
¿quién se fiaría de una moneda dirigida
por países como Rusia o China?
Además, ¿realmente podrían ponerse de acuerdo
sobre quien manda o como gestionarla?
No parece una misión nada fácil…
Y sea como sea, no lo dudéis, el dólar mantendría
el grueso de su influencia en la economía
mundial.
¿Por qué?
Ya os lo hemos contado con todo detalle aquí
en VisualPolitik.
Echad un vistazo a la descripción
Por ahora, en este vídeo lo que queríamos
era poner sobre la mesa otra amenaza en la
que los adversarios de Estados Unidos ya están
desarrollando…
Este es otro de los grandes riesgos contra
la Seguridad Nacional a los que se enfrenta
el Tío Sam…
Riesgos para los que hoy por hoy parece bien
cubierto…
Pero…
¿Solo hay riesgos externos?
¿Y si tuvieran las propias entrañas americanas
algún parásito dispuesto a causarles mucho
daño?
¿Alguna idea de lo que estamos hablando?
Pues…
Atentos.
T3 (¿UNA GRAN FRACTURA LOCAL?)
Queridos amigos, amigas, Estados Unidos es
un país con muchas fortalezas, pero también
con muchísimos problemas.
No dejamos de verlos por todas partes: la
inseguridad en muchas ciudades, el abuso de
drogas como el fentanilo, muchísimos reclusos,
una alta población sin techo y muchos otros
más.
Hablamos de problemas que están provocando
una importante fractura social.
Pero, por encima de todos ellos, hay un problema
que todos los analistas señalan como el más
peligroso de todos: la enorme polarización
política y social.
Sí, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, cada
vez más la política en Estados Unidos ya
no se centra únicamente en asuntos puramente
de gestión como los impuestos, la tenencia
de armas o la sanidad.
Ahora, las identidades han tomado también
el espacio político: la división de la sociedad
por raza, etnia, género e ideología ha cobrado
mucha fuerza.
Dicho de otra forma: el tribalismo se ha extendido
por la política americana y la polarización
sigue profundizándose cada vez más.
¿Creéis que exagero?
Pues fijaos lo que piensan los propios americanos.
Ya lo veis, más del 60% de los estadounidenses
dicen que la división y la violencia política
aumentarán en los próximos años.
Y, siendo honestos, es muy prob able que vaya
a ser así.
Desde 2016 la sociedad estadounidense se ha
partido prácticamente en dos.
La incursión en la política de una de las
figuras muy controvertida ha hecho mella en
la estabilidad social.
Muchos ya sabéis de quién os estamos hablando.
Exacto, de Donald Trump.
La situación ha llegado hasta tal punto que
los americanos tienden a ser muy pesimistas.
Tanto como para decir esto:
N6(Más del 40% de los estadounidenses cree
probable una guerra civil en una década.
The Guardian)
A ver, lógicamente, no parece muy razonable
pensar en una guerra civil al uso.
Pero todo esto si que podría terminar paralizando
o, incluso, colapso muchas de las instituciones
del país.
¿Por qué?
Muy simple: la polarización lleva a que las
alianzas políticas sean más difíciles de
lograr y las negociaciones se estanquen más
fácilmente.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Precisamente por esto, el mensaje de reelección
que publicó Joe Biden a finales de abril
de este año, no se centra en las amenazas
externas, sino en la gran amenaza interna,
la polarización de la sociedad.
Pero, seamos honestos, no es un mensaje especialmente
conciliador.
De hecho, señala a los republicanos y no
duda en acusarles de manera indirecta del
recorte de derechos y libertades en el país.
En fin…
Estados Unidos se enfrenta a nuevos retos…
Pero curiosamente los más peligrosos de todos
pueden ser los que tiene dentro de casa.
Ahora bien, llegados hasta aquí turno para
ti: ¿creéis de verdad que Estados Unidos
llegará a tener otra guerra civil?
¿Crearán al final los BRICS su propia moneda?
¿Creéis que esa moneda podría desplazar
realmente al dólar?
¿Logrará China superar a Estados Unidos
militarmente?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.